- Back to me having sex
with you, I don't want to.
- You're out?
- It doesn't sound like it.
- No, I'm out
because of his penis.
- [Blake] Would
you titty fuck him?
- Maybe.
- Show biz, Mom!
- We made it.
- Hey, Dad!
- We on the TV.
- [Adam] Show you tomorrow
when it's fully huge-d.
The king cobra is sleeping.
Okay.
- [Blake] Great.
- Well, until tomorrow, huh?
- [Adam] Yeah, it's hibernating,
it down in its hole.
- Put that up on the calendar
because I want to remember
to ask him about that.
- Alright, November 10th,
Adam's penis comes out.
- Fine, throw,
Fine, throw him in the trunk
What the fuck is his name?
- Montez.
- Martez.
- [Crew Member] Here
we go, still going.
Here we go, still going.
- [Adam] You fuck a lot
of dudes, don't you?
- There it is, kind of.
- Dude, that hits
me in the nuts.
- [Blake] Dude, sit in gum?
- [Anders] Cool dick, that's
like the realest dick.
That's the realest
dick in the world.
- It's so dope.
- [Blake] I'll never
talk, you black cops!
- What'd you call me?
- [Blake] The black
cops, I hate black cops
- No.
- [Blake] What?
- Oh no, don't say that.
- [Blake] Why?
- Well, there's several
black cops here.
You mean black ops.
- [Blake] Oh, yeah.
- [Adam] Unless Blake,
the character, is racist.
(burps)
- Oh.
- There it is, that's it.
- That's a part of it.
Can't wait to be
on a girl's show.
I was joking.
- Put the stuff on please
and I'll turn around.
- Ders, you should watch him.
- Why, you have a big
dick or something?
- Workaholics, season
four, that's a wrap.